Jake:一会儿刮彩票吗
Jake: Are we scratching the lottery tickets later?
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia:不是下雨了吗
Lucia: Isn't it raining?
Jake:修硕说停
Jake: Shure said it stopped.
Katrina: 今天晚上有啥安排吗
Katrina: Any plans for tonight?
Katrina: 你们下午干了什么
Katrina: What did you do this afternoon?
Jake:应该是拆屋子
Jake: Probably demolishing the house.
Katrina: 拆今天晚上拆屋子
Katrina: Demolish the house tonight?
Jake:对就是给你打包嘛
Jake: Yeah, to pack things up for you.
Jake:要把屋子给恢复原样
Jake: We need to restore the house to its original state.
Lucia:要领一个箱子有很多东西要装一下
Lucia: We need a box to pack a lot of things.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah?
Shure: 还有半个瓜在楼上
Shure: There's half a melon upstairs.
Shure: 然后你们想吃的话记得切着吃
Shure: If you want to eat it, remember to cut it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And...
Shure: 是遗嘱是吧
Shure: Is it the will?
Shure: 对遗嘱了
Shure: Yeah, the will.
Shure: 最后教再交代两句
Shure: Just a few last words.
Katrina: 那这些东西怎么办呀
Katrina: What about these things?
Shure: 然后线 归还
Shure: Then, return the cables.
Tasha:所以你们走
Tasha: So, you guys are leaving?
Tasha:你们回去
Tasha: Are you going back?
Jake:这就刷一刷
Jake: Just clean up a bit.
Tasha:回去了吗
Tasha: Are you going back?
Shure: 对我们准备回去了直接
Shure: Yeah, we're getting ready to leave directly.
Jake:就刷一刷
Jake: Just clean up a bit.
Jake:比如说那个盘子吗
Jake: Like the dishes, for example.
Katrina: 我说这些没有用完的
Katrina: I'm talking about the unfinished stuff.
Shure: 我的手机
Shure: My phone.
Jake:这些放哪呢
Jake: Where should we put these?
Katrina: 你带回去吗
Katrina: Are you taking them back?
Shure: 把这个都停掉
Shure: Stop all this.
Jake:嗯你想带走就带走
Jake: If you want to take it, take it.
Jake:带不走就放那吧
Jake: If not, just leave it there.
Katrina: 感觉扔掉好浪费啊
Katrina: It feels wasteful to throw it away.
Jake:是的是呀
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Tasha:扔掉好浪费啊
Tasha: It's wasteful to throw it away.
Tasha:但是带回去我在学校也没法做呀
Tasha: But if I take it back, I can't do anything with it at school.
Jake:好说
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake:卖掉
Jake: Sell it.
Tasha:卖掉
Tasha: Sell it.
Tasha:你卖分我一半就行
Tasha: Just give me half of the profit.
Jake:为什么 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Why? Hahaha.
Lucia:这个玉米淀粉是不是没拆没拆的感觉可以
Lucia: This corn starch seems unopened. It feels good.
Tasha:可是他要两他两包起卖
Tasha: But he wants to sell it in pairs.
Tasha:两包好像才5块钱
Tasha: Two packs are only 5 bucks.
Katrina: 主要是卖给谁啊
Katrina: Who are we going to sell it to?
Lucia:就是没拆的
Lucia: It's unopened.
Lucia:我们可以比如说大家装一下
Lucia: We can maybe pack it together or something.
Lucia:或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia:拆了的就不太好带或者
Lucia: Once it's opened, it's not easy to carry.
Tasha:玉米淀粉
Tasha: Corn starch.
Tasha:做汤可能会用到
Tasha: We might need it for soup.
Tasha:寄给我妈吧
Tasha: Send it to my mom.
Katrina: 哦他这能寄快递
Katrina: Oh, can they deliver it?
Katrina: 能上门取件吗
Katrina: Can they pick it up?
Jake:对这个可以
Jake: Yes, they can.
Jake:哦 那今天晚上让他上门取
Jake: Oh, let's have them pick it up tonight.
Shure: 杨老板我交交还
Shure: Jake, I'm going to return it.
Katrina: 柯欣呢
Katrina: Where's Kexin?
Tasha:噜噜噜在房间里
Tasha: Lulu is in the room.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 他们怎么了
Katrina: What happened to them?
Shure: 再见
Shure: Goodbye.
Katrina: 哦原来退伍啊
Katrina: Oh, they're retiring.
Jake:退伍啊是
Jake: Retiring, huh?
Katrina: 把骏马放下
Katrina: Put down the horses.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 立正 缩习
Shure: Attention, salute.
Jake:我们应该列队 然后
Jake: We should line up, and then...
Lucia:拎个枪什么的吗
Lucia: Carry a gun or something?
Jake:枪毙是吧
Jake: Execution, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Jake:我们第一位叛徒哈哈
Jake: Our first traitor, haha.
Jake:12点
Jake: 12 o'clock.
Katrina: 我们早上
Katrina: In the morning.
Katrina: 自己想什么时候走就什么时候走吗
Katrina: Can we leave whenever we want?
Katrina: 还是
Katrina: Or...
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:12点退房吗
Jake: Check out at 12?
Jake:就是12点之前
Jake: Like, before 12.
Shure: 行李放这
Shure: Leave the luggage here.
Shure: 哦他们那个刘帅和XBZ是开车来的吗
Shure: Oh, are Choiszt and XBZ driving here?
Jake:刘帅也来
Jake: Choiszt is coming too.
Shure: 刘帅来吗
Shure: Is Choiszt coming?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia:那一会是要过来吗
Lucia: Are they coming over later?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:XBZ要来
Jake: XBZ is coming.
Shure: 谢彬竹要来
Shure: Xie Binzhu is coming.
Shure: 让他明天帮我把把行礼带回去
Shure: Ask him to take my luggage back tomorrow.
Jake:他太惨了我靠
Jake: Poor guy, damn.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Lucia:他不是还发烧呢吗
Lucia: Isn't he still having a fever?
Shure: 哎呀他没死就行
Shure: As long as he's not dead, it's fine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈 这个话记住了
Tasha: Hahaha, remember that.
Lucia:救命
Lucia: Oh my god.
Katrina: 兄弟情
Katrina: Brotherhood.
Jake:别以为你自己不戴眼镜就
Jake: Don’t think just because you’re not wearing glasses...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我来看看还有什么能顺点回去
Shure: Let me see what else I can take back.
Jake:好你顺啥
Jake: What are you taking?
Lucia: 对啊 你北京本地
Lucia: Yeah, you’re local in Beijing.
Katrina: 顺点东西走吧
Katrina: Just take some stuff.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 是不是充电宝
Shure: Is it a power bank?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:充充电宝
Jake: Charging a power bank.
Jake:XBZ给你点
Jake: XBZ will give you one.
Katrina: 可以顺充电宝吧
Katrina: Can I take a power bank?
Katrina: 我正好缺一个
Katrina: I just need one.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Shure: 这我的了
Shure: This one's mine.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:我们明天走出去
Lucia: We're leaving tomorrow.
Lucia:把自己用的这个充电宝给他顺走
Lucia: Take the power bank we're using.
Shure: 我还有一个我的那个
Shure: I still have one of mine.
Katrina: 你要不要带点鸡蛋回去
Katrina: Do you want to take some eggs back?
Jake:啊行
Jake: Ah, sure.
Tasha:是这个吗
Tasha: Is it this one?
Tasha:是这个吗这有个黑的
Tasha: Is it this one? There's a black one here.
Tasha:哦 算了那就不是
Tasha: Oh, forget it, then it's not.
Shure: 有一个大的白的
Shure: There's a big white one.
Katrina: 你端一盒鸡蛋回去吧
Katrina: Take a box of eggs back.
Jake:唉 对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia:对刚好你在北京这个不容易散
Lucia: Yeah, it's just right, it's not easy to get in Beijing.
Katrina: 补点营养
Katrina: Get some nutrition.
Katrina: 还有你的咸鸭蛋
Katrina: And your salted duck eggs.
Tasha:带
Tasha: Bring them.
Shure: 哦 还有咸鸭蛋
Shure: Oh, there are salted duck eggs too.
Shure: 那箱子不好使
Shure: That box doesn't work well.
Shure: 我ipad 还没放时去
Shure: I haven't put my iPad in yet.
Shure: 酒我带了一瓶
Shure: I brought a bottle of wine.
Shure: 然后咖啡给我装好
Shure: And pack my coffee well.
Katrina: 瓜分
Katrina: Divvy it up.
Shure: 哦对杨老板还有报销账单我没领
Shure: Oh right, Jake, I haven't claimed the reimbursement yet.
Jake:哎哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:行行行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha:杨老板什么时候结
Tasha: Jake, when will you settle it?
Tasha:我的也没报呢
Tasha: I haven't claimed mine either.
Jake:好好好给你
Jake: Okay, okay, I'll give it to you.
Shure: 我们临走前把钱款两清
Shure: Let's settle all the money before we leave.
Katrina:  哈哈今今晚算账是吧
Katrina: Haha, are we settling accounts tonight?
Shure: 不当面结清
Shure: No, let's do it face to face.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你买了啥呀
Katrina: What did you buy?
Katrina: 他屋子好像也没买啥
Katrina: Seems like you didn't buy much for your room.
Shure: 我屋子里没买啥
Shure: I didn't buy much for my room.
Shure: 我吃饭点了
Shure: I ordered food.
Katrina: 你帮我点
Katrina: You ordered for me.
Katrina: 点外卖了是吗
Katrina: You ordered takeout, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来帮我摁个计算器家人们
Shure: Help me press the calculator, everyone.
Tasha:你等会帮我也摁一下
Tasha: Wait, help me press it too.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Tasha:算了你报吧
Tasha: Never mind, you calculate.
Tasha:我来帮你加
Tasha: I'll help you add.
Shure: 首先139块8
Shure: First, 139.8.
Tasha:139.8
Tasha: 139.8.
Shure的女友:那个点8也要算进来
Shure's GF: That 0.8 needs to be included.
Shure: 去加94
Shure: Add 94.
Jake:95哈
Jake: Make it 95.
Tasha:94
Tasha: 94.
Tasha:加
Tasha: Add.
Shure: 22块5毛7
Shure: 22.57.
Tasha:22.5毛7
Tasha: 22.57.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:那个7
Lucia: That 7.
Shure: 加40.8
Shure: Add 40.8.
Tasha:40.8
Tasha: 40.8.
Jake:写精确
Jake: Write it precisely.
Shure: 加96
Shure: Add 96.
Tasha:96
Tasha: 96.
Shure: 加49块5毛2
Shure: Add 49.52.
Tasha:49.5毛2
Tasha: 49.52.
Shure: 啊没有了
Shure: Ah, that's it.
Tasha:442.69
Tasha: 442.69.
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 然后还有等一下
Shure: And then, wait a second.
Jake:还有摸个0吧
Jake: Add a zero.
Jake:40 哈哈哈
Jake: 40, hahaha.
Jake:摸个0 40 哈哈哈
Jake: Add a zero, 40, hahaha.
Tasha:你怎么不说0.69嘞
Tasha: Why don't you say 0.69?
Tasha:摸个头吧
Tasha: Add it up.
Shure: 看看这就是资本主义的压榨
Shure: See, this is capitalist exploitation.
Shure: 家人们我们要
Shure: Family, we need to...
Tasha:警惕
Tasha: Be vigilant.
Shure: 警惕
Shure: Be vigilant.
Tasha:我都不敢把我的账单发给他看了
Tasha: I'm too scared to show him my bill.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Tasha:我这有2,000多的账要报
Tasha: I have over 2,000 in bills to report.
Shure: 啊34块9毛8
Shure: Ah, 34.98.
Tasha:34.9毛8
Tasha: 34.98.
Shure: 还有一个咖啡豆钱
Shure: And the coffee bean money.
Tasha:咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Shure: 咖啡豆是
Shure: The coffee beans are...
Lucia:我觉得我们天天在这演群口相声
Lucia: I feel like we're doing a comedy skit every day.
Shure: 148
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha:148的咖啡豆
Tasha: 148's coffee beans
Jake:这么整呢
Jake: What to do with this?
Jake:假的吧
Jake: Is it fake?
Shure: 嗯是真的
Shure: No, it's real.
Jake:哈哈哈嗯
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Shure: 它两包起卖主要是
Shure: They sell it in packs of two mainly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:总共这么多钱
Jake: So, this much money in total.
Jake:对 好 你是谁
Jake: Right, okay. Who are you?
Shure: 我是哈哈哈
Shure: I'm... Hahaha.
Shure: 没事咱咱扫码就行
Shure: No worries, we can just scan the code.
Tasha:哈哈哈哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 二维码收款ok
Shure: QR code payment is okay.
Tasha:来帮我加一下
Tasha: Come, help me add this.
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Jake:多少钱 625点
Jake: How much? 625, right?
Shure: 哎 摸个零吧
Shure: Ah, round it off.
Shure: 625就行了
Shure: 625 is fine.
Jake:哎
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 大方吗杨老板
Shure: Generous, right, Jake?
Jake:哎是挺好
Jake: Ah, it's pretty good.
Shure: 给你省了1/100新币 哈哈哈
Shure: I saved you 1/100 of a new coin. Hahaha.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Tasha:你怎么不帮我啊
Tasha: Why don't you help me?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Jake:来互摁是吧
Jake: Come on, press together, right?
Jake:来 摁一下
Jake: Come, press it.
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30.
Lucia:你看这就是单次博弈的坏处
Lucia: See, this is the downside of single-round games.
Lucia:你们俩要是经常互相摁的话
Lucia: If you guys keep pressing for each other,
Lucia:双方就会
Lucia: Both sides will...
Jake:啊就有默契是吧
Jake: Ah, then there will be a tacit understanding, right?
Tasha:30烤箱
Tasha: 30 for the oven.
Shure: 30
Shure: 30.
Tasha:加24跑腿
Tasha: Plus 24 for delivery.
Shure: 24
Shure: 24.
Tasha:装修房间493
Tasha: Renovating the room, 493.
Jake:跑腿
Jake: Running errands.
Shure: 496
Shure: 496.
Tasha:加25的地毯
Tasha: Adding a 25 carpet.
Shure: 25地毯钱
Shure: 25 for the carpet.
Tasha:加达美乐点餐220
Tasha: Adding Domino's order, 220.
Shure: 220加
Shure: 220 added.
Tasha:跑腿16
Tasha: Errands, 16.
Shure: 16加
Shure: 16 added.
Tasha:盒马702
Tasha: Hema, 702.
Shure: 哈哈 哦
Shure: Haha, oh.
Jake:我草哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my, hahaha.
Shure: 噢 盒马
Shure: Oh, Hema.
Shure: 都让人家付的
Shure: All paid by someone else.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha:厨房用纸10块
Tasha: Kitchen paper, 10 bucks.
Shure: 10块
Shure: 10 bucks.
Tasha:夹板20
Tasha: Plywood, 20.
Shure: 20
Shure: 20.
Tasha:蛋奶油55
Tasha: Egg cream, 55.
Shure: 55
Shure: 55.
Tasha:低筋面粉7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour, 7.
Shure: 7
Shure: 7.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's, 568.
Shure: 568的麦当劳
Shure: 568 for McDonald's.
Katrina: 麦当劳也是你点的
Katrina: McDonald's was also your order.
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Errands, 12.6.
Tasha:跑腿15
Tasha: Errands, 15.
Tasha:昨天的披萨点餐169今天中午的饭
Tasha: Yesterday's pizza order, 169. Today's lunch.
Tasha:说吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Shure: 2,366块6
Shure: 2,366.6.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 没没算错吧应该
Shure: No mistake, right?
Tasha:不知道你啊
Tasha: I don't know, you tell me.
Tasha:你不要坑我
Tasha: Don't cheat me.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:你你你坑的不一定是你吧
Jake: You, you, you might not be the one being cheated.
Shure: 哈哈哈我再再来一次
Shure: Hahaha, I'll do it again.
Shure: 再来一次
Shure: Let's do it again.
Shure: 我怕
Shure: I'm scared.
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30.
Shure: 30
Shure: 30.
Tasha:跑腿24
Tasha: Delivery 24.
Shure: 24
Shure: 24.
Tasha:装饰房间493
Tasha: Room decoration 493.
Shure: 493
Shure: 493.
Katrina: 咱不需要给他贴那个订单截图吗
Katrina: Don't we need to attach the order screenshot?
Tasha:地毯25
Tasha: Carpet 25.
Shure: 25
Shure: 25.
Tasha:达美乐220 跑腿16
Tasha: Domino's 220, delivery 16.
Tasha:盒马702 厨房用纸10块 夹板20
Tasha: Hema 702, kitchen paper 10, clipboard 20.
Tasha:淡奶油55
Tasha: Cream 55.
Katrina: 我一会算
Katrina: I'll calculate it later.
Tasha:低筋面粉 7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour 7.
Lucia:对我在想我装修的那个
Lucia: Yeah, I'm thinking about my renovation.
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's 568.
Katrina: 累了
Katrina: Tired.
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery 12.6.
Katrina: 算这个有很多零零碎碎
Katrina: Calculating this has a lot of bits and pieces.
Tasha:昨天的跑腿15
Tasha: Yesterday's delivery 15.
Katrina: 反正500肯定拉满了我
Katrina: Anyway, 500 is definitely maxed out.
Tasha:今天中午点餐169
Tasha: Today's lunch order 169.
Shure: 没错
Shure: That's right.
Lucia:我之前算了
Lucia: I calculated it before.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Lucia:我好像没到
Lucia: I don't think I reached it.
Shure: 两遍都是2366
Shure: Both times it's 2366.
Lucia:不过过快了
Lucia: But it went too fast.
Jake:两遍都是啊
Jake: Both times, huh?
Jake:行多少
Jake: Alright, how much?
Shure: 3 2366.6
Shure: 3, 2366.6.
Jake:来来来扫扫扫
Jake: Come on, scan, scan, scan.
Tasha:你也扫啊
Tasha: You scan too.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Good.
Tasha:谢谢你杨老板
Tasha: Thank you, Jake.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go have a feast.
Tasha:还写什么论文呀
Tasha: What about writing the paper?
Jake:写什么论文吃大餐
Jake: Write a thesis? Let's have a feast!
Jake:大餐去了
Jake: Let's go for a feast!
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go have a feast!
Katrina: 哈哈带人家吃点好的
Katrina: Haha, take everyone out for something good!
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow
Jake:哎多多少
Jake: Hey, how much?
Jake:2,000
Jake: 2,000
Shure: 366块6
Shure: 366.6
Jake:366 好
Jake: 366, okay
Jake:2300
Jake: 2,300
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 2366块6
Shure: 2,366.6
Tasha:呃还少带了一个6
Tasha: Uh, you missed a 6
Tasha:好开始
Tasha: Alright, let's start
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
老板:我靠
Boss: Oh my god
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK
Shure: 杨老板的
Shure: Jake's
Tasha:杨老板到底转了多少
Tasha: How much did Jake actually transfer?
Tasha:可恶啊哈哈
Tasha: Darn it, haha
Tasha:他怎么把0加点加上了
Tasha: Why did he add the extra zero?
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Alright
Jake:不应该加上吗
Jake: Wasn't he supposed to add it?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake:我还缺啥吗
Jake: Am I missing anything?
Tasha:其实我觉得可以加
Tasha: Actually, I think you can add it
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:加什么
Jake: Add what?
Tasha:加上那个点
Tasha: Add the point
Jake:再加6分钱是吧
Jake: Adding another 6 cents, right?
Shure: 对我的充电宝
Shure: Yes, my power bank
Katrina: 充电宝还分人吗
Katrina: Do power banks belong to specific people?
Katrina: 我们不都随便拿
Katrina: Don't we all just use them?
Shure: 不是我有一个自带的充电宝
Shure: No, I have my own power bank
Katrina: 哦哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh
Jake:你还损失了一个充电宝
Jake: You even lost a power bank
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow
Tasha:算上你这笔钱
Tasha: Add that to your expenses
Tasha:我这个什么微信收款
Tasha: What about my WeChat payment?
Tasha:累积到1万块钱了
Tasha: It accumulated to 10,000 yuan
Jake:哦这么真
Jake: Oh, so real.
Shure: 然后还有还有什么吗
Shure: And then, what else?
Tasha:好我的报销完毕
Tasha: Okay, my reimbursement is done.
Shure: 这几天的工资没有谈
Shure: We haven't talked about the salary for these few days.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Jake:你你找找你的充电宝
Jake: You should look for your power bank.
Jake:你你找找
Jake: You should look for it.
Jake:对总共就两层
Jake: Yeah, there are only two floors in total.
Shure: 啊这个是我的啊
Shure: Ah, this one is mine.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:给他换给他换一个
Jake: Give him a replacement.
Shure: 我的没电
Shure: Mine is out of power.
Katrina: 算上今天
Katrina: Including today.
Jake:对欠4天
Jake: Yeah, 4 days owed.
Jake:欠欠4天工资
Jake: Owed, 4 days of salary.
Jake:然后你你红包抢过吗
Jake: And did you grab the red envelope?
Tasha:欠4天工资
Tasha: Owed 4 days of salary.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我一天没领
Tasha: I didn't receive any for one day.
Jake:你不你第一天抢的红包啊
Jake: Didn't you grab the red envelope on the first day?
Shure: 啊昨天我看一下
Shure: Ah, let me check yesterday.
Tasha:啊是吗
Tasha: Ah, really?
Jake:对
Tasha:到底是从哪天开始算
Tasha: So when exactly did it start?
Tasha:我也不记得算了
Tasha: I can't remember, nevermind.
Katrina: 但是我领过一个这种
Katrina: But I did receive one.
Katrina: 70的这种
Katrina: One of 70.
Shure: 到是这两个我都领过了
Shure: I've received both of these.
Katrina: 哦我这还有昨天超市的账我去
Katrina: Oh, and I have the supermarket bill from yesterday.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this one.
Shure: 143这个
Shure: This one is 143.
Jake:来来来我给你给你算算
Jake: Come, come, let me calculate it for you.
Lucia:这瓜还挺好吃啊
Lucia: This melon is pretty tasty.
Tasha:啊我也觉的
Tasha: Ah, I think so too.
Lucia:非常的
Lucia: Very much.
Katrina: 我抢了161
Katrina: I grabbed 161.
Katrina: 我靠我抢了3
Katrina: Wow, I grabbed 3.
Jake:应该是从
Jake: It should be from...
Shure: 1200减去
Shure: 1200 minus...
Tasha:你看你
Tasha: Look at you.
Tasha:哎每天整那么花里胡哨自己都忘
Tasha: Hey, every day you make such a fuss, you forget yourself.
Jake:没没忘没有
Jake: No, I didn't forget.
Jake:差点就忘了
Jake: Almost forgot though.
Jake:就这个300
Jake: It's this 300.
Jake:第第一天300是吧
Jake: The first day was 300, right?
Jake:嗯然后第二天157 这算吗
Jake: Yeah, and the second day was 157. Does that count?
Jake:什么嗯
Jake: What, um...
Jake:就是你你157
Jake: You had 157.
Jake:哎你143领掉了别的应该没有什么
Jake: Hey, you got 143, there shouldn't be anything else.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:哎还有这个153领掉了是吧
Jake: Oh, and you got 153 too, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 904
Shure: 904.
Jake:好来扫你
Jake: Okay, let me scan you.
Shure: 还有904
Shure: There's also 904.
Shure: 应该没了吧
Shure: That should be it, right?
Shure: 唉怎么怎么付款吗呢
Shure: Hey, how do I pay?
Shure: 收款码在哪了呢 唉
Shure: Where's the payment code? Hey.
Shure: 904杨老板
Shure: 904, Jake.
Jake:到
Jake: Here.
Shure: 感谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha:904这是什么
Tasha: 904, what's that?
Shure: 提供打车
Shure: Providing a ride.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这是
Jake: That's it.
Katrina: 祝大哥顺顺顺什么
Katrina: Wishing you good fortune.
Jake:三 四天 四天的工资
Jake: Three, four days' wages.
Katrina: 顺水
Katrina: Smooth sailing.
Tasha:钱 怎么还有4块呢
Tasha: Money, why's there still 4 yuan?
Jake:因为他之前摸了个红包
Jake: Because he got a red envelope before.
Shure: 顺山顺水顺财神
Shure: Smooth mountains, smooth waters, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 顺顺顺顺顺财神
Katrina: Smooth, smooth, smooth, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehehehehe.
Jake:啥东西啊
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 哦我有钱有钱了
Shure: Oh, I have money now.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 现在有好多钱
Shure: Now we have a lot of money.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 再见了杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure: 我会想你
Shure: I'll miss you.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 不会在外面全消失了吧
Shure: We won't completely disappear outside, right?
Shure的女友:没关系这全是我的
Shure: It's okay, all of this is mine.
Katrina: 你们俩咋回去
Katrina: How are you two getting back?
Katrina: 打车还是什么
Katrina: Taking a cab or what?
Shure: 打车 坐地铁还是有点远打车回去
Shure: Taking a cab. The subway is a bit far, so we'll take a cab back.
Katrina: 打车回去多少钱
Katrina: How much is the cab ride back?
Shure: 100
Shure: 100.
Shure的女友:不到吧
Shure: Not that much, right?
Shure的女友:不知道好像
Shure: Not sure, I think.
Katrina: 报哈哈哈
Katrina: Report it, hahaha.
Shure: 这个报吗杨老板
Shure: Should we report this, Jake?
Jake:这个也能报
Jake: You can report this too.
Shure: 你哎呀操打车
Shure: Oh my, taking a cab.
Jake:你先打你先打你先打
Jake: You go first, you go first, you go first.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: OK哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: OK, oh my goodness.
Jake:打完
Jake: Finished calling.
Katrina: 哇回武汉能报吗
Katrina: Wow, can you report going back to Wuhan?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:打车回武汉是吗
Jake: Taking a cab back to Wuhan, right?
Lucia:哦那我打车回家
Lucia: Oh, then I'll take a cab home.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 打车
Katrina: Taking a cab.
Tasha:那我打车回个家
Tasha: Then I'll take a cab home.
Jake:回哪杭州啊
Jake: Where to, Hangzhou?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 老板大气
Shure: Jake's so generous.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:要打车回三亚
Lucia: I'll take a cab to Sanya.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 我我们把杨老板给榨干了
Shure: We drained Jake dry.
Jake:哈对又惦记又没钱了
Jake: Yeah, thinking about it, no money left again.
Alice:什么打车回三亚
Alice: What, taking a cab to Sanya?
Lucia:嗯 对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Alice:打车回三亚
Alice: Taking a taxi back to Sanya.
Lucia:我 没有没有开玩笑
Lucia: No, no, I was joking.
Tasha:他说打车报销
Tasha: He said the taxi fare will be reimbursed.
Alice:什么时候搭车
Alice: When are we taking the taxi?
Tasha:现在啊
Tasha: Right now.
Jake:明 啊 现在
Jake: Yeah, now.
Alice:谁走啊
Alice: Who's leaving?
Jake:他走
Jake: He is.
Alice:我也得走
Alice: I have to go too.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 我还第一天长安街的半天的工资
Shure: I still have my half-day wages from Chang'an Street.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 那个算吗
Shure: Does that count?
Jake:第一天
Jake: The first day.
Shure: 去长安街录像的那个
Shure: The day we recorded on Chang'an Street.
Jake:哎那应该
Jake: Yeah, that should.
Shure: XBZ没给我
Shure: XBZ didn't give it to me.
Katrina: 私吞了
Katrina: He pocketed it.
Alice:什么叫把谢老板
Alice: What do you mean by pocketing it?
Shure: 给谢彬竹发了
Shure: He sent it to Xie Binzhu.
Alice:什么榨干
Alice: What do you mean by exploiting?
Katrina: 杨杨老板
Katrina: Jake.
Katrina: 老板名字说怎么工资就别想要了
Katrina: If you mention the boss's name, you can forget about your salary.
Lucia:就是蟹老板
Lucia: Yeah, Mr. Crab.
Tasha:谢老板
Tasha: Mr. Xie.
Lucia:蟹老板
Lucia: Mr. Crab.
Jake:蟹老板我们做汉堡
Jake: Mr. Crab, we're making burgers.
Tasha:卖汉堡的
Tasha: Selling burgers.
Jake:哈哈哈 我们一起做汉堡去
Jake: Hahaha, let's go make burgers together.
Shure: 130
Shure: 130.
Shure的女友:你打车了吗
Shure: Did you call the taxi?
Shure: 138块5毛4
Shure: 138.54 yuan.
Alice:你们带伞了吗
Alice: Did you guys bring umbrellas?
Alice:只有这没下雨
Alice: It's only not raining here.
Alice:朝阳都下了
Alice: It's raining in Chaoyang.
Alice:要不拿出来
Alice: Should we take them out?
Katrina: 你今天晚上也要走啊
Katrina: Are you leaving tonight too?
Jake:等一下啊
Jake: Wait a minute.
Alice:啊对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Jake:看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina: 学校有事吗
Katrina: Is there something going on at school?
Alice:对明天有事
Alice: Yeah, there's something tomorrow.
Alice:明天不想早起直接在寝室睡
Alice: I don't want to get up early tomorrow, so I'll just sleep in the dorm.
Katrina: 真好
Katrina: That's nice.
Jake:第0天是150
Jake: Day 0 is 150.
Jake:你你说的是哪一个
Jake: Which one are you talking about?
Shure: 还负一天
Shure: There's still a negative day.
Shure: 你记不记得我提前拿到那个去长安街
Shure: Do you remember I got that thing early and went to Chang'an Street?
Shure: 跟那
Shure: With that...
Alice:所以现在在
Alice: So now it's...
Jake:那算150里啊
Jake: That counts in the 150.
Shure: 那算这个
Shure: That counts.
Jake:对对对算150
Jake: Yes, yes, it counts in the 150.
Katrina: 对对对算钱呢
Katrina: Yes, yes, it counts for the money.
Tasha:算工钱
Tasha: Counts as wages.
Katrina: 他问老板包工头要要清钱在这
Katrina: He asked the boss for the full payment here.
Shure: 那就报销一个打车费啦好吧
Shure: Then reimburse a taxi fare, okay?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:哎我没戴眼镜
Alice: Oh, I forgot my glasses.
Shure: 谢谢老板谢谢老板
Shure: Thank you, boss, thank you, boss.
Jake:别打专车就行
Jake: Just don't take a premium taxi.
Shure: 没有没有没打专车没打专车
Shure: No, no, didn't take a premium taxi.
Shure: 快车都没敢打
Shure: Didn't even dare to take a quick ride.
Shure: 咱打的是
Shure: We took...
Tasha:拼车啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: A shared ride, hahaha.
Katrina: 特惠
Katrina: A special deal.
Alice:呆会我打车能报销吗我比较近
Alice: Can I get reimbursed for a taxi later? I'm pretty close.
Jake:都都可以
Jake: Yes, yes, that's fine.
Jake:可以没问题
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Alice:但我没戴眼镜我现在就要把它卸了
Alice: But I didn't bring my glasses, I'll take them off now.
Shure: 但是这个打车费有点贵
Shure: But this taxi fare is a bit expensive.
Jake:什么你可以戴眼镜
Jake: What? You can wear glasses.
Shure: 能报吗
Shure: Can it be reimbursed?
Alice:眼镜呢
Alice: Glasses?
Katrina: 多少钱
Katrina: How much?
Tasha:多少钱
Tasha: How much?
Lucia:多少钱
Lucia: How much?
Tasha:138块5毛4
Tasha: 138.54 yuan.
Katrina: 小声我以为两开头呢小声
Katrina: Quiet, I thought it was over 200, quiet.
Jake:100也也行吧
Jake: 100 is also okay, right?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no
Jake:好说
Jake: No problem
Shure: 谢谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:杨老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Jake, where are your glasses?
Shure: 今年啊顶会
Shure: This year at the top conference
Shure: 我感觉靖康的名字要要JKR
Shure: I feel like Jingkang's name will be JKR
Shure: 这个名字要出现10-10 20次
Shure: This name will appear 10-20 times
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Alice:老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Boss, where are your glasses?
Shure: 这些算算多吧
Shure: This is quite a lot, right?
Lucia:我也不太了解
Lucia: I don't really know
Katrina: 算多
Katrina: It's quite a lot
Shure: 算多
Shure: It's quite a lot
Katrina: 直接博导了
Katrina: 我博导都没发生这么多
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure: 院长了
Shure: The dean
Shure: 哈哈哈杨院长
Shure: Hahaha, Dean Yang
Tasha:受不了
Tasha: I can't take it
Shure: 哎呦这个名字听着朗朗上口
Shure: Oh, this name sounds so catchy
Tasha:受不了啦
Tasha: I really can't take it anymore
Jake:可以
Jake: It's possible
Alice:所以眼镜在哪啊
Alice: So where are the glasses?
Jake:你眼镜
Jake: Your glasses
Katrina: 那我也来算账
Katrina: Then I'll do the math too
Katrina: 我去拿我的笔点点
Katrina: I'll get my pen to mark it
Alice:这个不是我的
Alice: This is not mine
Katrina: 点晚饭了吗
Katrina: Did you order dinner?
Jake:你眼镜在
Jake: Your glasses are
Katrina: 感觉我还是没啥胃口
Katrina: I still don't have much of an appetite
Alice:打完了吗
Alice: Are you done?
Alice:我现在要开始拆喽
Alice: I'm going to start unpacking now
Jake:好你眼镜在楼上吧好像
Jake: Okay, your glasses are probably upstairs
Katrina: 谢彬竹说他要住住你的房间
Katrina: Xie Bin Zhu said he wants to stay in your room
Tasha:XBZ让他吃完晚饭再来我们
Tasha: XBZ, let him come after dinner
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:XBZ晚上还来吗
Alice: Is XBZ coming tonight?
Shure: XBX晚上来吗
Shure: Is XBX coming tonight?
Tasha:他说他发烧了来换个床
Tasha: He said he has a fever and wants to switch beds
Katrina: 他说他陪他过来唠嗑
Katrina: He said he's here to chat.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我说修硕走谁跟我玩
Katrina: Hahaha, I told Shure to come play with me.
Alice:不是明天中午就结束吗
Alice: Isn't it over by noon tomorrow?
Tasha:他说他过来唠嗑
Tasha: He said he's here to chat.
Jake:不是谢彬竹
Jake: Isn't it Xie Binzhu?
Jake:谢彬竹他到底发不发烧啊
Jake: Is Xie Binzhu having a fever or not?
Shure: 他发着 他确实是发着 发着
Shure: He is, he definitely is, he is.
Jake:他发着就更适合聊天
Jake: If he's got a fever, he's more suitable for chatting.
Tasha:他太想聊天了
Tasha: He really wants to chat.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 他一直想套我的八卦你知道吗
Katrina: He keeps trying to get gossip out of me, you know?
Katrina: 昨天晚上没问完就走了
Katrina: He left last night without finishing his questions.
Shure: 30 37度7还在外面坚持
Shure: 37.7 degrees and still hanging in there.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:这冷风中是吧 哈哈哈
Jake: In this cold wind, right? Hahaha.
Shure: 他今天应该比昨天还热
Shure: He should be hotter today than yesterday.
Alice:还是充电宝
Alice: Still a power bank.
Shure: 跟他保持点距离
Shure: Keep some distance from him.
Katrina: 对我也感觉
Katrina: Yeah, I feel that too.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 如果我也头疼怎么办
Katrina: What if I get a headache too?
Jake:那那不用保持距离
Jake: Then there's no need to keep distance.
Jake:那我们跟你保持距离
Jake: Then we'll keep our distance from you.
Jake:跟你们俩保持距离
Jake: Keep distance from you two.
Katrina: 我昨天真的是
Katrina: Yesterday, I really...
Katrina: 要么就是不能加那个青提还是怎么的
Katrina: Maybe it's because I can't add that green grape or something.
Alice:怎么没充电宝
Alice: How come there's no power bank?
Jake:充电宝可能有吧
Jake: Maybe there is a power bank.
Jake:充电宝 拔吧拔吧
Jake: Power bank, pull it out, pull it out.
Jake:咱也
Jake: Let's also...
Shure: 杨老板太大气
Shure: Jake is so generous.
Shure: 以后 杨老板像 多多财运
Shure: In the future, Jake will have lots of wealth.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 他老板说他请的助手太混了
Shure: His boss said his assistant is too lazy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 但杨老板你看我给你省了500块钱房屋装修费
Shure: But Jake, you see, I saved you 500 bucks on renovation costs.
Jake:哎那确实那确实
Jake: Yeah, that’s true, that's true.
Tasha:省怎么省呢
Tasha: How did you save?
Lucia:他没装修啊
Lucia: He didn’t renovate.
Jake:省成这样省成这样
Jake: Saved it like this, saved it like this.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 那咱是不是省了吗
Shure: So, did we save it?
Jake:省啊省啊
Jake: Save it, save it.
Shure: 就是因为我本来
Shure: Because I originally...
Tasha:你就说花的值不值吗值
Tasha: Just say if it was worth the money, it was.
Jake:值  哈哈哈
Jake: It was. Hahaha.
Shure: 就是数据集这要保证多样性
Shure: The dataset needs to ensure diversity.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 就是有人需要装修有人不需要
Shure: Some people need renovations, some don't.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 你下次给我住毛坯房就行
Shure: Next time, just let me stay in an unfinished house.
Shure: 只要工资到位
Shure: As long as the salary is fine.
Tasha:给给
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Shure: 倒挂着住也没关系
Shure: I don't mind staying upside down.
Tasha:住那个
Tasha: Stay in that...
Jake:那行下次就这么定了
Jake: Alright, let's settle it like that next time.
Tasha:那个8块钱一天的那个
Tasha: That 8 yuan per day place.
Jake:啊富塞倒碑塔
Jake: Oh, the Fusaidaobeita.
Lucia:你这个研究逐渐变态在下去要塞道去了
Lucia: Your research is getting weirder, soon you'll end up in the tunnel.
Shure: 阴塞道那是什么鬼
Shure: What the heck is the tunnel?
Shure: 我要倒立
Shure: I have to stand on my head.
Shure: 怎么着也得500一天吧
Shure: It should be at least 500 per day, right?
Tasha:我靠那还是让他住房吧
Tasha: Damn, then just let him stay in a house.
Shure: 我比房子都贵
Shure: I'm more expensive than the house.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  董叉叉问我什么时候离开
Katrina: Jack asked me when I'll leave.
Jake: 问你什么时候离开
Jake: Asked when you'll leave?
Katrina:  他说靖康应该要在你们后收拾东西
Katrina: He said Jingkang should pack up after you guys.
Katrina:  他他是不是要过来帮忙
Katrina: Is he coming to help?
Katrina:  所以他要协调自己的时间是吗
Katrina: So he needs to coordinate his time, right?
Jake: 他可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 他为什么不问我呢
Jake: Why didn't he ask me?
Tasha:我哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  有道理哈
Katrina: Makes sense, haha.
Katrina:  卧槽这这小狐狸真就没了
Katrina: Damn, this little fox is really gone.
Katrina:  哎 我靠
Katrina: Oh, damn.
Shure: 好我可以先滚蛋了
Shure: Alright, I can leave now.
Jake:有钱 可以
Jake: Got money, it's fine.
Jake: 吃个西瓜压压惊
Jake: Have some watermelon to calm down.
Tasha: 谁下呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's next? Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么抖了呢杨老板你手
Shure: Why is your hand shaking, Jake?
Jake:什么东西呀
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 好惨呢
Shure: So miserable.
Alice:这窗帘真的很像婚纱的质地啊
Alice: This curtain really feels like wedding dress material.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:所以做婚纱为什么不能用窗帘
Alice: So why can't we use curtains to make wedding dresses?
Lucia: 可能说亲肤吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe because of the texture, haha.
Tasha: 可能用的是一块布
Tasha: Maybe it's just a piece of fabric.
Tasha: 但是为了显肤
Tasha: But to make it look good on the skin.
Alice: 我以为他走了
Alice: I thought he left.
Alice:有一股工厂的味
Alice: It smells like a factory.
Lucia: 对 新的这些布料
Lucia: Yeah, these new fabrics.
Lucia: 没事 不用洗了
Lucia: It's fine, no need to wash it.
Alice: 让刘婷拿着玩吧
Alice: Let Liu Ting play with it.